hello youtuber verse this is your
personal astrophysicist coming up cosmic
queries edition of Startalk this one on
x-rays in the universe this is Startalk
I'm your host Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist and today it's a
cosmic queries x-ray imaging
astrophysics edition you don't think we
had one of those did you what we did
because we have one of the world's
experts in that very subject sitting
with me right now I've got with me Kim
Arkan Kim welcome thank you get your
title correct here is visualization and
emerging technology lead for the Chandra
x-ray observatory yes wonderful
and they didn't just pull you out of the
ether you've got some chops I'm holding
your book called magnitude scale of the
universe and I'd love this on the cover
it's got a mouse a human brain a bowling
ball a hot-air balloon and earth it's
like what scales are they and you open
the book and it lays that stuff out and
it talks about when things are big and
small and how to think about them
relative to one another and this stuff
we we confront every day in modern
astrophysics cool how do you wrap your
head around the scale of things and you
need to visualize it to know how to do
it best there's other ways we fumble
ourselves trying to explain it and so
you so beautiful book thank you and
thanks for bringing a copy here and
mykos Chuck hey Neil how I welcome back
to Startalk
absolutely it's a pleasure yes alright
and you're tweeting at Chuck nice comic
yes and and you're instagramming at
Kimberly Cowell Kimberly Cowell
keo wal it's my maiden name okay so
Kimberly Kalaheo wal okay okay Kimberly
okay but since you're a visual person
Instagram yes yeah so we're gonna all
look for that
yeah so you got some questions for us
Jeff absolutely let's do this yes you
know we have of course solicited
questions from all over the interwebs
and we've got some good some good ones
here but we always start with a patreon
patron because of patreon patrons give
us money
oh yeah and since we are cheap [ __ ]
I'm slowly getting used to them yeah you
don't like that you don't like anything
to do with money no no justice was my
idea I'm like give us money we'll do
whatever you want
first question all right first question
what would be the most exciting find
that you would have via x-ray telescope
like what would be the piece de
resistance so to speak
this is resets ok this is Jesus who from
from page from patreon patreon okay
Jesus well I mean I think there's a lot
of if you ask that question of a number
driven people there'd be a lot of
different answers I think like for me in
general with astronomy you're making the
images so you get you know I know I do
I do I get topic it's too exciting for
me just with my biology background and
anything to do with finding life
possibility for life on on other planets
I mean when I first started working for
Chandra exoplanets like weren't really a
thing like this was like the late 90s
and they weren't really I think maybe
they were one or two discoveries 1995
right exactly so my problem raised now
yes they are
there's thousands of them I think and
Chandra has some really interesting
capabilities to study especially the
effects of the the host star and how
that might have habitability issues with
its you know children planets so I think
anything to do with eggs and planets for
me that would be super exciting so this
is extra information brought to us by
x-rays yeah about these objects we
already know how about objects that we
would know nothing of were it not for
their x-ray signature so alright put at
the top of that list oh all right well I
think really here your x-rays for
exoplanets are supplementing she'll have
your data
the bigger puzzle the bigger yes give me
one where the x-rays are the only pieces
in the puzzle well so I'm too much like
a multi-wavelength astronomy junkie here
anyways but yeah I feel like these days
it's all about how the different kinds
of light are each one tool in the tool
box and astronomy right and it's truly
about how all of those pieces fit
together so x-ray astronomy complements
really well with radio astronomy with an
optical I mean it's really it's hard to
pick this one okay so this is the
healthiest way to think about that yeah
that you are cog in a wheel right puzzle
piece to a larger organized
understanding of the universe yeah and
with the addition of like gravitational
wave science holy window that's a more
yeah that's a multi messenger it gets
exciting I mean there's just there's a
lot to go there so I can't just pick one
just have one I like that like that and
are you showing off your cell phone here
look at maybe look at that I mean this
is NGC 602 it's a beautiful stellar
evolution area baby stars being born
nursery nursery lots of babies in there
you've got this the purple is the x-ray
data from Chandra and then there's also
some infrared data from Spitzer you
created that image one person of course
right
yes that's and you scientists are always
so damn humble you know it can't be
otherwise would smack you down cuz you
could right yeah and you guys kind of
all know the nature is always more
clever than any of us right oh I like
that nature is always more clever than
any of them oh yeah
yeah and sometimes it's more clever than
all of us combined Wow
so one thing so just to to to emphasize
your x-ray data is part of other data
that's combined to make that image
astronomy again at its best this is kind
of a great observatory classic with
Chandra Hubble and Spitzer um which i
think is really beautiful and it just
helps tell the story you know x-rays I
think are just such Andrews x-rays
obviously visible light and bits is
infrared so yeah two very different
branches of the spectrum very much but
combined to make one image so our eyes
could see that broadly right so if you
had a sensors in x-rays visible and
infrared mm-hmm well you'd be able to
put this all together and we you'd look
up and you see that and you see that
right so if you were predator you could
actually measure that or or Geordi or
Geordi LaForge or in Star Trek
correct right yeah yeah you could tune
that sucker up yeah you know you know
Geordi had the opportunity not to be
blind and he turned it down yeah in an
episode of Star Trek you know and I
think it's because he actually saw your
image well the thing is we are
practically blind when you consider how
narrow is the slice of the
electromagnetic spectrum our retina
shows us we are practically boy wow you
know you said you know you open a book
and it has the rainbow you know the
colors of the rainbow Rose you look
Reggie Biff right ray don't you love
green blue indigo violet them can't
forget indigo right and so it fills the
page and then but you look at the entire
range right and I'll recite that now
goes from from high energy to low energy
you go from gamma rays right x-rays
ultraviolet right violet indigo you do
gorgey bit backwards right violet indigo
blue green green red no not green yellow
orange orange yellow red okay okay then
you come out of the red you get infrared
infrared and then you get microwaves and
they get radio waves
Wow when you put all that on one page
visible light is this tiny little sliver
sliver so if you have like a piano in
front of you it'd be like human vision
is
see and maybe a couple keys not quite an
octave around I've been listening to
Beethoven's Ninth Symphony which is
never doubt three keys yeah yeah that's
terrible
yeah so we're basically buy so he did
there I hate my eyes now I hate my eyes
so let me ask you this then are there
any animals that see oh yeah outside of
the spectrum oh yeah and a little
insects are told Paul about ultraviolet
right and you know that they like
ultraviolet
okay this is this is how we know we are
smarter than insects okay okay evidence
we are smarter than insects all right
okay cool no one's stepping on us to
tell us we we we invented bug zappers
which are intense in ultraviolet and
they so I can't stop it
exactly and that's how we know we are
smarter than they are
mmm and bug bulbs which you don't see
much anymore they're kind of amber right
they don't repel bugs bugs don't see it
so their entire sensitivity to light is
shifted towards the blue end into the
ultraviolet and it dangles off the other
end some red and orange so it's not that
they avoid the red bulb over your picnic
table they don't see it at all they
can't see it at all yeah and if you put
a bug zapper at the end of the lawn
right they all go to the bugs amber so I
just want you'd appreciate that we are
smarter than comes in it's bugs we
should just rely on our an alien
invasion if they were smart enough to
get here and we're too stupid to leave
here something tells me they're gonna
have the equivalent of a bug zapper for
us like a concert yeah well you know
just like mom I got a free concert and
good food no one comes out to tell you
not to go - that must be the best
concert ever it's been going on for six
days and nobody's come out
we would be putty in the hands of a
smarter species for sure all right next
question
all right here we go Pinta bots on
instagram wants to know this since you
guys were talking about the different
types of light in the spectrum what is
the difference between Chandra x-ray
Observatory and James Webb telescope is
it just the spectrum of light or what
what else do they do that is different
let's start out with the orbit so what
is Chandra in uhm so Chandra is in a
highly elliptical orbit that goes about
a third of the way to the moon
Chanos about the size of the school bus
it weighs maybe four to eight hundred
kilograms and like that yes weighs one
sixth of that yeah interesting thing
about Chandra is it was I'm pretty sure
still was the heaviest thing that the
Space Shuttle ever launched the fact
that it was so massive meant that and I
didn't actually learn this until many
years later um the fact that it was so
massive meant that it was a more riskier
ride for the astronauts than it would
have been with a lighter payload their
abort scenarios for example were more
challenging but I didn't know that at
the time so yeah so chander was large
and in charge and it was fortunately
perfect far to get it up into space
and says that's that orbit and so James
Webb is a million miles on the other
side of the Moon right so they want that
away from Earth interference right yeah
so James Webb is an infrared based
telescope and again different parts of
the spectrum we've tuned differently and
so they have their targets of interest
their objects of affection in the
universe are different yeah but then you
bring them all together and you get the
point so now you mentioned the orbits
this is a question coming from a Chuck
nice on Facebook here in the officer let
me just comment about say something a
little more about James Webb go ahead so
no charges in the big elliptical orbit
so it's orbiting Earth James Webb is in
a lagrangian point ah it is a point
where all forces that would otherwise
move it are stable right and so you put
it out there and it takes very little
station-keeping
to just keep it there
and this is the these famous Lagrangian
points where we imagined you build stuff
right because you just get all your
hardware time just leave it right you
leave it sitting around just hang it's
the garbage patch it'll collect it I
need a bolt or screw their hands right
there it doesn't fall to anybody's
surface so they would imagine to be a
little more useful than they've turned
out to be it turns out we can make
things that are orbiting it's not that
hard because once you bring something up
into orbit it orbits with with you yeah
yeah it's not but anyhow though I do
love the Lagrangian point like as as a
as a place like you know total cool all
right so now let me ask you this okay as
these as these orbits happen are they
are they staying on a fixed point or are
they observing different quadrants as
they move around so Chandra goes a third
away to the moon at its farthest point
and then it was about sixteen thousand
kilometers to earth at its closest point
so it's this nice elliptical orbit and
it's got they did that for like optimal
observing capability so that it has the
most time to essentially be looking out
at the universe gotcha
but you know our way from Earth far away
from Earth exactly but yeah I think
what's really interesting about well for
one thing I think it must have gone like
2.7 billion miles
I mean kilometres by now over 20 years
which is anything fantastic and you
think about like tenders never had a day
off in like 20 years
doesn't even have like an it looks hard
put them right I know how perfect that
had to work when it was launched so
anyways but I'm not sure what James Webb
is doing but right so what's not up yet
waning of this broadcast yes but so
these these things have gyros that
enable you to know where you are where
you're pointing and so you give it
ascent coordinates up there and you pick
out your object of interest and gather
data so there are some I think I
understand the point of that question
there are some telescopes that only
observe one light it's fine and they
hammer that for bigger that's better
deeper data
Kepler did that right Kepler was one
patch of sky looking there was a lot of
stars but it was still one patch looking
for exoplanets
and because it had to go back looking
for variation rights in the host star a
so one set of data is not good enough
you got to go back and back and back and
then your pair all the fare all right so
and let me take this moment this let's
go over just who these people are
okay so James Webb was the he was head
of NASA during the 1960's cool yeah and
but the he was that I think it was the
first person who we named a telescope
after that was not a scientist so I love
is some political stuff going on in the
back in the back room that's kind of
cool door launch - oh yeah yeah normally
you name you name it after after launch
your name blows up but then it was
renamed chandra after Subrahmanyan
Chandrasekhar who was a very famous
Indian American Nobel laureate who
studied things like white dwarfs and
stuff like that very nice and he also
did so let me see here there it is
Subramanyam Chandrasekhar yeah a
radiative transfer so one of the more
brilliant among us who okay I'm through
I can't even with you what I'm just done
with you what what that like seriously
well you got issues what I can't believe
that
okay people at home I'm just gonna wait
let me let me just just open up okay
here here's to you it's her story's just
I'm here it is radio traffic exactly as
principles of invariance what is that
what is wiggly line and by the way so
this just goes on for page after page so
jerk page of this pages are just nothing
but actual equations just have to
question after equation I have seen
papers that are easy to understand and
sir
so check if you write a book like this
you get a telescope named after several
books that really were the definitive
word on those subjects and they're still
used in graduate school yeah it was a
naming contest we actually had a contest
for the naming and it was a teacher and
a high school student that picked the
name Chandra as the winning entry they
did some excellent research and so we
got to take a break okay we have more
questions coming up on the x-ray
universe with theme park I'd say that
right what I tried to friend you this
kid I try to French comic con Chuck nice
we'll be back in a few moments we're
back to start off in cosmic where is the
x-ray edition and I've got the leading
visualization person for the Chandra
x-ray telescope Kim Ark I'm Kim welcome
to Startalk to your first timer I hope
you get your back yeah and Chuck hey
always there you do there for me I am
always here for you my friend I love you
too okay so what do you have
let's go to made this name up
alright go addy Adam Adam Latoya Adam
auroria I'm gonna go with that on
Instagram was to know how many more
stars can we detect with a Chandra x-ray
Observatory then we can see with our
naked eye and can we detect EXO planet
transits we shaped that question yeah
look up at the night sky the human eye
can see about in the total sky that is
below and above you about 6000 stars a
cup of few nebulae you know with the
naked eye so how boldly different if you
could just turn on x-ray vision in it in
a Chandra sense
what do you begin to then notice what
begins to pop I think it's more than
just the stars so I guess it's um
quality over quantity right it's not
just the numerical number that we're
gonna be looking at but more
like telling about what they are so for
example if you looked at a patch of the
sky of
Orion Nebula for example and you looked
at that it's the closest stellar nursery
to the Sun all right in the
constellation among the stars with
conformation Orion you can look at that
in optical light and you'll definitely
see a lot of stars but as soon as you
look at an x-ray light you're gonna see
the same tiny small patch you might see
like I don't know 1700 x-ray sources but
those aren't gonna just be plain old
stars I mean you know not that stars are
just plain and all but you know maybe
you might see binaries you might see
black holes you might see other types of
these celestial objects so I guess for
me it's just yeah it's not the quantity
so much it's the quality of what you're
studying and then you're also going to
see a few submission kind of like some
of that hot bath that those stars might
be sitting in so hot hot gases will
radiate x-rays and you're not gonna see
that with your naked eye and you're not
gonna see with your regular telescope
right either right right so the whole
new world opens up right another example
would be something like Cassiopeia A the
supernova remnant right so you can look
at that in optical light would you not
like you do all but you know it's not
like it's something that is very
esoteric to be honest but supernova
exploded right I forgot the year that
that happened but there's a remnant of
this exploded star and we kind of knew
it was there but now Chandra gives us a
whole other view of it whole other world
it's really amazing to look at I mean
you can look at it with optical light
from like the Hubble Space Telescope and
you'll see this beautiful filamentary
structure I'm a very visual person
obviously so I'm like lacking my images
but you see this nice delicate
filamentary material around the 10,000
degree mark right kind of looks like a
hollow shell so you can look at Caffe
with the chantix Observatory and it
looks completely different it's like
literally death come alive it's a solid
looking sort of death coma thing yes
well it's death but it's you know it
does lead to future generations animated
death yeah it is moving
but it's amazing is you can trace like
where the iron is dispersed and where
the argon and the silicon is and it just
makes us incredibly gorgeous nebulae to
look at new stars have arrived from the
ashes of that which has burned good now
can I hang what you're very cool it's
Cassie I always forget is that the
brightest source of x-rays in the sky or
is there another x1 is a Scorpio
Scorpius x1 okay but Casa is really
bright and it's great for chance see now
you had that you had to do it what what
had to go you know I was cool with
Cassie okay had to go to scope scope and
and what a Scorpio and was the Scorpius
the consulate okay I'm old enough okay
I'm holding all y'all okay I worked at
the Center for Astrophysics which is a
big x-ray place up in Cambridge
Massachusetts as an undergraduate nice
and for my summer project I worked on
one of the earliest x-ray telescopes
that were launched so their wooo-hoooo
which was an x-ray telescope right and
and the reception is sort of Star Trek
but she was not the receptionist dude
she was lieutenant first of all yeah
this is a communications officer
so the first telescopes that go up they
just kind of look for anything that gave
up x-rays right and then it created a
catalog suite and you they numbered the
x-ray sources within each constellation
that's so by order of brightness and so
in Scorpius that the brightest one was
at x1 so some so x1 is but it's also
Cygnus x1 that's a good black hole
candidate and so there so the when you
see the X in the one we got our first
x-ray telescope all right Cass a was
named before we we had x-rays so and so
now the detection of those so you know
oh by those early telescopes it was just
to know that they're even there at all I
was gonna say yeah yeah so what night
you got Chandra x-ray astronomy is like
I mean there are a lot of people on this
planet whose whole lives have been the
length of x-ray
astronomy like the field is so young I
think I mean it really got going late
40s early 50s and then by the time
detectives yeah exactly by the time I
was born there was a good detector on
Skylab by timing kids were born like you
know Chandra had launched an X and a
Newton was launched and now they're
working on new generations of x-ray
telescopes in 1999 2019 is a 20th
anniversary okay now before that you're
looking at images like a hundred times
kind of dimmer or fainter much cleaner
and I mean it started like looking at
the Sun to just get X rays from the Sun
first because it's a nice nearby target
Sun bright enough you think it would
like fry chander off no one should be
looking at the Sun but yes and then yeah
with like a guru and Einstein like all
these other missions it's just been an
amazing like compact amount of x-ray
astronomy that's happened and just a
handful it took a normal course of
evolution so you you first got a note
you want to learn that there's any kind
of source of extract here there there
did their blunt instruments right then
you kind of wonder what it is you might
do some calculations but still you don't
know and the later generations you say
now that I know they're there and I know
what kind of signal is giving me let me
devise a detector that can more
precisely measure that and or mint or
something dimmer and so like you say you
see the dimmer ones you get more
precision in your image right you start
making x-ray images right and now
Chandler's images are so sharp and
beautiful I mean when you're looking at
things like supernova remnants and it's
just so much detail that you're seeing
nevermind what the next generation of
x-ray telescopes will be able to do will
the next generation say you know back in
2019 she was she was nothing yeah the
best thing the best thing if you if you
were obsolete if I yes all right should
we go another question let's do this
this is
Chris cherry from Instagram says what is
the next light spectrum will be
observing in the universe or observing
the universe in all of them all the
above I mean I guess it depends on what
they mean by that question if they mean
what's next to be launched I mean
hopefully the James Webb will be the
next to be launched and that'll be
infrared and then beyond that it's
whatever is in the budget and what other
agencies are a great answer whatever's
in the budget it's true spectrum
whatever is in the budget but ideally
all the light we want all the way very
cool but here's an interesting challenge
okay so that's so radio waves have very
long wavelengths right and one bits of
evidence of that is those who remember
televisions that had rabbit ears they're
detecting radio waves as television
signals and the length of the rabbit ear
is commensurate with the length of the
radio wave that it's trying to capture
so that's okay
so suppose you want to detect a radio
wave that's a meter long or 10 meters
long or kilometer long how are you going
to detect that you need a detector that
is at least that size right so you can
get a whole wave length in there or at
least half a wavelength you need some
fraction of that wavelength hitting and
being able to focus it suppose there's
something out there that makes a radio
wave that is the diameter of Earth's
orbit around the Sun who's detecting
that so there could be phenomena in the
universe that is washing across the
entire solar system and we don't have
detectors that can pick it up Wow
I do like radio waves if I had to pick a
second favorite besides x-rays I think
it would be radio that's a nice pair of
waves right there yeah they really are
they're very complimentary yeah it's
true opposite parts but it's attract I
mean it really does what's the highly
used in our culture radio waves for
communication and x-rays for very very
cool all right all right
could there be - oh sorry Julie H who
comes to us at time traveling on Twitter
mm-hmm like that she says could there be
technology like Street View on Google
Maps that visits various points just
points in the universe so we have Google
Mars I think it's called you can look
that up Google Mars comer maybe it smart
so Google come whatever that it's almost
like like Street view of some of the
data on Mars and that's really amazing
getting more three-dimensional which i
think is the point she's kind of getting
it there data of our universe is really
hard once you're going beyond nearby
objects in the solar system and you're
going farther out past the stars it's
really hard to get some sort of usable
dimensional data on that to then turn
into like a 3d model that you can tour
in like a street view touch them so you
think you don't do 3d modeling for
Chandra we do you do it's just heart
actually I do things you brought to
show-and-tell I did bring something
which does not help the audio yeah so it
is a kind of globular looking structure
and it has many different nodes that are
jutting out from it and it looks like a
tumor removed from somebody yeah but
there's a reason for that
it looks like fossil calcified coral
that's good it's because why it looks
biological it's because we actually used
brain imaging software adapted from some
local area brain scientists in the
Boston area to make it that we use their
software so that's why it looks more
brainy ish or biological ish than you
would probably expect that's funny
because before we sat down I picked this
up and I said is this like a fire in
neuron yes yes well I mean if you look
at visuals from the micro versus macro
now
speaking my language because of my
biology background but you can see so
many similarities in the way that you
process those data right but what you're
holding is a 3d model of Cassiopeia A
our good friend that we were talking
about earlier the supernova remnant so
cool yeah ten eleven thousand
light-years away and you're able to hold
a version in your hand essentially
because of the Doppler effect
so did you 3d print that yeah this is 3d
printed okay yep
so we work so the Doppler effect gives
you depth information right exactly
so Tracy Delaney she was a scientist who
first worked on that she was at MIT at
the time and she was essentially
figuring out what information was moving
away and what was moving towards well
she was their imaging labs MIT has a big
favorite but we hooked her up with the
folks who were working on the medical
imaging software translation which was
called astronomical medicine
hybridization yeah so scale is an issue
though obviously when you're holding
something that's small this is like four
inches across for those listening what
we can do maybe we'll photograph it in
real life it's like the surface areas
maybe 40 million billion times the
surface area of our Sun and planets and
you can toss in Pluto if you like it
doesn't matter all right Chuck only you
have to bury the hatchet with a what
they dwarf planet I was about to say put
a hound dog okay yes exactly
bloodhound yeah yeah all right do we
have time let me hear let me hear the
question RA I'm gonna give you the
question this is Tom Rick's from
Facebook he says do you think virtual
reality will ever allow the human brain
to completely comprehend the immense
distances between planets stars and
galaxies or is this something that will
never fully grasp we will answer that
after this break naughty what I did
there you go it's called a tease oh this
is Startalk cosmic queries x-ray
astrophysics edition we'll see in a
moment
Startalk cosmic queries x-ray
astrophysics edition was celebrating the
20th anniversary of the launch of the
Chandra x-ray telescope one of the great
observatories up there with Hubble and
James Webb and the rest of them each of
them targeting their their window to the
universe nice I got Kim Kim Ark and
hello yes and Chuck yeah so we left off
left people dangling yes where can
virtual reality help us comprehend the
the scale of sizes and distances and
things let's make this a more broad
visualization question right part of
your job Kim it's to get people to see
things we don't otherwise see or to
grasp scale and texture and phenomenon
that is not otherwise accessible to us
looking at on our Instagram account so
so with what role do you see that you
play in getting us closer to the
universe that's a great question I think
mostly my job is to just sort of oversee
all the various visual platforms that we
can take chander data to I mean we it's
not just photographs not just images
yeah I mean Chander one of the great
things when you have a telescope that's
been up there for so long as you just
have a fantastic archive of data to work
with and as technology has developed in
other sectors you have all of these new
platforms to try it out with so we were
talking about 3d printing earlier and
the idea of what you do with 3d models
she does stay current with all that you
do we exploit it in service yeah when I
started working for Chandra Cassy PA was
one of the first objects we ever looked
at right and it was beautiful in us in a
flat two-dimensional image and I was
amazed never what I have imagined in
fast forward 20 years and I'm holding a
version of it in my hand or walking
inside it in virtual reality like those
technologies were not a reality at the
time so with things like virtual reality
or augmented reality mixed reality data
sonification using sound there are all
of these ways sonification yes so add
another sense to the interpretation of
the data
she's also good for blind people exactly
dr. Wanda Diaz actually has done a lot
of work around that my kind of perf
the world would be a virtual reality
application where you have the the
visual of course but then you have the
layer of sound that's also spatially
attached so you know where things are
and then also like a haptic layer so you
can actually vibration so like you know
in your phone it's called that's what we
use I don't know but yes essentially by
being able to feel those vibrations as
you're moving through the the remnant
right so there are all these
applications none of which were around
will be through the remnant so you we
have the 3d model and you become a
journey you journey through the model
exactly it's now the scale is my god I
used to have that at the Franklin
Institute it was a heart oh yeah so
think of that except virtual right but
then having cues of sound and touch and
it's a wholly different understanding
and experience of that information now
going back to the question of scale I
mean as soon as you get out of Earth's
side scale and even smaller than that
it's really hard for human understanding
and Relations of what we know so whether
that will actually help people
understand and comprehend some of these
vast scale I don't know but it doesn't
it might help but here's the thing it's
it's just not everything that we see we
we imagine on the scale that we see it
yeah because that's the scale and so
scale in which our senses were forged
correct so the problem is that even if
you weren't able to demonstrate it your
brain would be resistant to actually
then revision it that way because you're
so used to looking at you know the world
through the eyes that you have which is
like Neil does this thing where he shows
which I the first time I saw it because
he did it for me I was like get out of
here and he showed me just where the
moon and the Sun and the earth are and
it was like and we just did it with like
a basketball and something else and then
we did it in a regular room and I'm like
you got to be kidding me like you know
what I mean so even even being able to
see it in the plan
that's crazy so yeah I don't think the
human brain could ever comprehend those
fast scales it's just too much cool this
is good stuff
all right I got another quick one just
while we're there yeah you might ask you
see all these stars in these photos and
you say will stars ever collide well
they do rarely but they do and they can
and it's interesting when that happens
but up to appreciate how rare that is if
there were four bumblebees in the United
States
flying randomly there's a higher chance
that two of them will accidentally bump
into one one another then for two stars
to collide in a gallon just for ba-bum
beliefs you look at their size and the
distance between them that's kind of
what you're getting the size of a star
relative the distances between and by
the way if there's only four bumblebees
we're all dead next all right this is
four we go to whitening room here we go
Jonathan gallon wants to know this hey
it's Jonathan from Edmonton how far away
from my own you know what we did this
already but I'm gonna I'm gonna give it
to you anyway he's taking it one step
further than the last question there's a
follow what we'll call it
how far away for are we from a Star Trek
like stellar cartography room like they
like they have on the holiday in the
next generation in the next generation
the holodeck I really like that question
it's a great quest and we're actually
just starting to experiment with
Holograms
oh but screen based Holograms so not you
know just sort of appearing you might
help me obi-wan Kenobi you're my screen
base it's there I mean and I think with
like missions like Gaia and others you
know building this sort of nice 3d map I
mean the universe is three people the
Gaia mission got 3d data on millions of
stars in our galaxy right our world is
3d so being able to bring some of that
3d nature into a way that we can
visualize understand
and then explore it I think it's really
important I really do and it's awfully
fun cool I don't even know if we have
enough questions left for for lightening
lightening rather we just do it that we
can just we just chill chill with him
all right let's chill with it this is
let me slip in a question here oh yeah
so let's can we just go back to basics
yeah when you're gonna make a simple
color image of something that has no
color and you're using your x-rays to do
so what are your steps well so first we
get the data from whatever object it is
if we want to use cafe as our example
this is the favorite object of the day
the favorite object it's actually one of
my favorites if I wanted minute but we
first get the data in you know it's when
it first comes down it's actually
transmitted in encoded in form of ones
and zeros then it goes through some
software and then it's translated into a
table that shows the X&Y position of the
observation on the time and the energy
of each of those packets of light that's
struck the detector during the
observation then it's like yet more
softly by the way we could measure
visible light in the form of energy we
just don't the way we do it is we
measure it by color right so oh this is
a blue photon and this is a red photon
and we just say it's blue in a red but
if we did a Chandra thing on this we'd
say that this is the higher energy
photon this is a lower energy photon and
the blue would have higher energy than
the red so it's really the same thing
but they have a whole other the
detectors measure this in energy so the
vocabulary and the steps are are shaped
for that right okay so sorry to
interrupt
slap that in there okay go more software
we finally get the visual representation
of the object and I like to use that
word that term for a reason because I
think there is this idea that these
images of the universe are giant cosmic
selfies you know any means snap done and
they're not they really do take people
like me or like whoever to do the
creation step because it is like that
you can't see so then you create the
visual representation of the object and
then you refine it you have to get rid
of artifacts or bad bits of data you
have to smooth it you might have to crop
in the field of view that you need and
then usually the last step is color and
I like to you know
slice and dice an image by energy level
essentially so the lowest energy x-rays
will be assigned read the medium green
and the highest blue unless we're adding
it to optical image from Hubble or
Spitzer infrared image that means you
can't take their color exactly you have
to share you have to share the and then
you compile it together and get your
color image all stuff you couldn't see
even if it's optical range most of this
stuff is you can't see because human
eyes are so feeble yeah Wow that is
incredible yeah that's incredible so
you're actually layering layering this
stuff one on top of another and then to
form the image itself that's pretty but
your retinas doing that so the combs of
your retina yeah they're they're red
sensitive cells they're green sensitive
cells and they're blue RGB right and
light comes in it triggers one cell or
another to pay how much energy it has
but we save it depending on what color
it is right I mean it's an energy thing
it's all about energy and so you trigger
certain amount of the red green and blue
and if it's more red than blue or more
blue than red it shapes what colored it
turns out to be that your brain
interprets so it's the same thing as
your eyes Wow yeah a computer screen or
whatever yeah that's if you have a look
at RGB instructions in the computer code
it's just a level what how much of the
point is if the colors are you can make
arbitrarily any color what you have the
RGB
just a mixture of those three and that's
why and it only works there with light
don't try that at home with paint right
you mix RGB paint yeah you get mugged
you get mine right right yeah exactly
yeah now I I did know that I just and my
boy figure that out who Isaac Newton oh
yeah he he knew that people kind of
maybe figured that white light can make
a spectrum right but he took the
spectrum put it back through a prism and
it made white light right and they're
freaked people out yeah how do you get
red orange yellow green blue violet and
get white light right yeah well thank
you Isaac Newton if it weren't for him
my boy would not have had a
a livelihood not a livelihood with I
wouldn't been sustained growing up cuz
my father was a printer printers do yes
actually take light and they mix it to
create color CMYK exactly right and yeah
and that's from the exact same principle
that you just said there you go just I
that's excellent very cool there's some
new revelation what we're doing here
okay so we got two minutes let's see
what we have right here
Skynet is aware from Instagram says this
so slow Chandra was originally launched
in 1999 how has the technology advanced
since it was launched do we have better
technology to twenty years later that is
more sensitive so okay can I ask that
differently okay okay you ready yeah
okay at what point do you say we've got
such better technology let's drop
Chandra in the Pacific Ocean and put up
the better technology because you're
spending money on something that was
conceived and designed not twenty years
ago but 25 years ago when it was still
on the drawing well if you have an
embarrassment of riches in that
situation fantastic but that's not the
reality so we don't have a way better
x-ray telescope
come on twenty years ago well they take
a team on the Macintosh was five years
old take turns
there was no spark for smartphones
Chandra is still cutting-edge it's still
an amazingly it's just an incredible
piece of equipment still I mean they had
to smooth Chander's mirrors so much like
all the technology that was necessary to
create that has then actually led to all
of these fantastic spin-off technologies
that we get to benefit from every day in
medicine in imaging and focusing a huge
like there was so much work that had to
go into figuring that out so I think we
can write off that for a while I want to
say don't put Chander at an early grave
it's doing beautifully that's very cool
very cool all right do we have time for
another one
can I can I end with a little story
story time okay get rid of these stupid
questions
okay so there's there's a guy his name
is riccardo giacconi generally
considered by among us to be the father
of x-ray astronomy okay and he knew that
if you're gonna have if you want to see
x-rays you have to do it from above the
atmosphere because x-rays don't make it
through the ozone and other particles in
our atmosphere so you need something
above the atmosphere if you're gonna see
the universe in x-rays well if you gonna
launch something it can't be too heavy
because it's expensive to launch heavy
things it's got to be light it's got to
be portable so he was one of the
founders of American science and
engineering a company based in Cambridge
Massachusetts that pioneered small
portable x-ray detectors when was this
in the 1960s hmm what was going on in
the 1960s oh there were hijacking planes
to Cuba people were taking guns on
planes Congress said we need a way to
stop guns getting on planes
we need x-rays in airports damn
we have American science and engineering
providing the first x-ray detectors at
airports enabled as these portable
devices because they're trying to put
him on a satellite into orbit Wow and he
would ultimately get the Nobel Prize as
you at Kim had introduced him earlier in
the show and I was on the committee the
Presidential Committee that awarded him
the Presidential Medal of Science and
when you get the presidential know of
science everyone goes to the White House
I get invited to the White House and
here comes riccardo giacconi to the
White House to get the Presidential
Medal of Science and you go through the
security app house before you get into
the White House itself and what does he
walk through an American slice an
engineering metal detector Wow and it's
right and didn't and why have a like
metal hip or a plate missing I just
thought that was that was so the Bohr
closure yeah to the fact that the
president is being protected by
technology that he helped pioneer and
he's getting the President's Medal of
Science for half
pioneered just that x-ray astronomy is a
gift that keeps on giving
and we tell that story an accessory to
war with my co-author of Aswang nice and
just it's the it's astronomy technology
affecting security it's one more way
where our penchant for trying to destroy
one another has led to a modern-day
marvel so Kim Ark can thank you for
coming on Startalk you're first I hope
we can get you again not that far away
you're you're in Providence yeah
Providence Rhode Island indeed yes yes
and so great to have you on the list
Chuck always good to have you my
pleasure Neil you've been listening to
possibly even watching Startalk cosmic
queries x-ray astrophysics edition I'm
your host Neil deGrasse Tyson and as
always I'd review
[Music]